- Please welcome the
one and only Adam Scott.
(audience applauding)
- [Adam] Hey Drew.
- Hi.
- Oh my God, I'm such a fan of yours.
I'm freaking out.
- Well, it's the same right back at ya.
I'm such a big fan of yours
and have been my whole life, essentially.
- I read in some research,
is it true that you have
watched "Sex in the City:
And Just Like That"?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I watched "Sex and the City"
when it was on originally like we all did
and then I got COVID last February,
so I got COVID classic,
like I got the original COVID,
like pre-vaccine COVID
and was trapped in an
apartment by myself in New York
and just watched all of "Sex
in the City" in like two days
and hadn't seen it in
20 years or something
and it is incredible.
It's incredible what they were doing
and so far ahead of their time.
It's a terrific show.
- Okay, so are you a Carrie, a Samantha,
a Charlotte or a Miranda?
- I feel like I'm a Miranda probably.
- Oh my God, I've become a Miranda.
- You have.
- Not the "And Just Like That" Miranda,
but the "Sex and the City" Miranda.
- That's the Miranda
I am as well, I think.
- Okay, perfect.
I like the "And Just Like That" Miranda,
and in fact, Cynthia Nixon
came on the show to talk about it, I love,
I liked "And Just Like That"
because at first I was like,
I want my old "Sex in the City"
and then I was like,
what am I talking about?
We're all older, we're not the same,
they're moving on, I need to
too and then I got on board.
- Yeah, me too and I also
felt a little protective of it
and that people were really
quick to jump all over a show
starring all these women in their 50's.
I feel like we should
applaud that and applaud them
putting these women on a show together.
It's great.
- Okay now your amazing wife,
is it true that when your wife
first met you, she was like,
"Oh no, no, no, no, you're an actor."?
- Yeah I mean it's only,
she's smart so of course she
would be a little trepidatious
dating an actor.
And also one that kind of wasn't,
like I didn't really have
anything to show for it really.
I was just trying to jump
from guest spot to guest spot
and had a little apartment,
like, I don't know why she dated me,
but I'm really glad she did.
- Did she ever say like,
"Oh, actors are typically dot dot dot
and that would be my fear?"
Did she give you any reasons
other than just being an actor?
- Yeah, I think kind of
full of themselves and,
I think full of themselves
and I think she's right.
Like I think actors are
really kind of self-involved
but for good reason because
the thing we are doing
and the thing that we're selling is us.
So it's hard not to be self-involved
to a certain degree as an actor but,
so I was working pretty hard
to show her that I wasn't self-involved
to prove her wrong.
We were just shooting the other night,
we were shooting "Party Down"-
- Which is everyone's so excited about.
You just finished shooting.
"Party Down" is coming back,
it's like the cult classic,
everybody freaks out,
this is so exciting,
okay sorry, not to, I
didn't mean to interrupt.
- No, no, no, not at all.
We were just shooting on
Saturday night, we just finished
and Jennifer Garner's on the show now
and she and I were sitting there
and someone's getting us coffee
and asking us if we wanted a snack
and we just realized we're like babies,
like actors are like toddlers
and everything on sets at
least is sort of done for them.
So it is ridiculous how
pampered actors are.
- It can be true,
but look at you
and I'm sure your wife is so happy
that she gave you a chance
and you seem like such a good person.
- Oh, thanks Drew.
Well, I'm so, so glad she
gave me a chance as well.
I'm very lucky.
(upbeat music)